hey everyone we got our hands on axiom  verge 2 a little early and wanted to  show you all some gameplay of the first  15 minutes drop a like if you're excited  to see the series return and subscribe  for more gameplay videos just like this  enjoy  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  you  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  uh  [Music]  so  foreign  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  ah  huh  three  time  so  so  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  from  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  [Music]  um  [Music]  [Music]  go  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hey  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  bye  yeah  [Music]  [Music]  hmm  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  true  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you